[Applause]
[Music]
the people's republic of china is the
world's second largest economy the
world's largest manufacturer and
increasingly a major player in
international news but visualpolitik
fans despite this it's still a very
aloof and largely unknown country whose
image continues to be surrounded by
great cliches and myths which either
never wear or at best no longer are a
reality at least not entirely what we're
going to look at are the three big myths
that surround the chinese economy the
three big lies are half truths that
you've surely heard many times and that
you've probably believed so let's get
cracking
myth one just one large export factory
[Music]
china has changed a lot in recent
decades since den jiang ping began its
opening up process in 1978 china has
experienced the biggest economic takeoff
in history over the past 40 years this
country has averaged annual economic
growth of nearly 10 and its
inflation-adjusted gdp per capita has
increased more than 24-fold enabling
more than 800 million people that's more
than the entire populations of latin
america canada and the netherlands
combined to leave poverty behind and yes
it is true in this entire evolution the
export sector did play a key role but
with 1.4 billion consumers and a middle
class that includes more than 600
million chinese the economy of this
country goes far beyond that
perhaps the biggest myth about china's
rapid modernization and economic
development is that its growth has been
export-led however china's economic
transformation owes much more to its
successful adoption of a market-based
domestic economy and its vast
mobilization of savings for investment
stephen dover head of the franklin
templeton institute in fact as stephen
dover himself points out the weight of
exports in china is barely 19 of gdp a
proportion similar to that of countries
such as brazil or india but much lower
than that of countries such as canada
france italy or the uk and it does not
even come close to germany the way of
exports over gdp in germany exceeds that
of china by more than 25 points yes in
absolute terms china is the world's
largest exporter almost 10 of all goods
exported worldwide come from this
country but this is because we are also
talking about the economy of a huge
country china does export a lot but the
real economic heart of the country lies
in its local market specifically in its
investment market and its productive
factors market or what is known as its
gross capital formation to give you an
idea china saves and invests locally
more than 40 of its gdp approximately
double the usual ratio in western
countries
[Music]
machines cranes apartments dams roads
investment in housing transportation
infrastructure and production centers
have been responsible for most of the
country's economic growth in fact the
main economic problems now facing china
have to do precisely with this feature
we are talking about all about problems
of over-investment misallocation of
capital and low levels of productivity
precisely for this reason for years the
chinese government has been trying to
boost local consumption so this economic
structure evolves towards a more model
similar to that of wealthier countries
in other words if we talk about the
prospects and evolution of the chinese
economy the key is not so much in
exports as in its capital markets and
productive factors
myth 2 foreign investors are fleeing
china
okay that the chinese economy is not
living its finest hour it's an open
secret the trade war the pandemic xi
jinping's common prosperity campaign
skyrocketing energy prices the real
estate crisis and the covet zero policy
are all events that are hitting the
chinese economy however despite this it
cannot be said that foreign investors
are leaving on mass or that the
government itself is restricting foreign
investment
it is one thing to freeze an investment
project or move it to another country in
order to seek greater diversification of
production chains but quite another to
retrace the path followed in recent
decades and keep one thing in mind today
there is no alternative to china in fact
play close attention to what happened in
2020
25th of january 2021 china moves towards
world leadership overtakes the us for
the first time as the main destination
for foreign direct investment and then
in 2021 it once again recorded the
largest fdi foreign direct investment
inflow in its entire history one of
every five dollars of direct investment
worldwide went to this asian giant
[Music]
what's more the chinese government not
only does not reject foreign investment
but they are very clear that they need
it proof of this is that in recent years
beijing has been opening more and more
sectors of its economy to foreigners and
has also made it easier for
international companies to have 100
controlled subsidiaries in the country
for example as we've told you here on
visualpolitik in 2021 the chinese
government authorized u.s investment
banks to operate in the country with
wholly owned subsidiaries it is true
however that the coveted zero policy is
dealing a severe blow to this openness
not least because it is closing the
country's borders to human capital
however it is understood that this could
only be temporary that at least is the
expectation
myth three china rivals the united
states economically
the third and last great myth has to do
with china's economic power and its
ability to look the united states in the
eye the world bank estimates the chinese
economy adjusted for the price
deferential is already above that of the
united states however that can lead to a
huge misunderstanding you see china has
advanced leaps and bounds but its
distance from the richest countries is
still galactic in fact we are talking
about a country that still cannot be
considered wealthy according to world
bank data its gdp per capita is just
over ten thousand dollars which is a
quarter of the gdp per capita of the
european union and barely 20 of that of
the united states and let's not forget
that this is what determines its
purchasing power and international
investment
the chinese economy is very large
because we are talking about the most
populated country on the planet
approximately one out of every five
inhabitants of the earth are chinese but
of the 1.4 billion people that we find
in the people's republic of china only
600 million could be considered
middle-class in addition gdp is a crude
indicator that presents many problems it
does not measure productivity
consumption of productive factors or
surplus production which is ultimately
what determines wealth
[Music]
this is what explains why according to
credit suisse data the wealth gap
between us families and chinese families
has widened by 12 trillion dollars since
2011. we also have to take into account
that we are talking about a very large
country with many differences not only
in terms of population but also in terms
of territory unlike the large coast
cities and inland areas are still
relatively poor in short china cannot be
considered a wealthy country nor does it
seem that at least for now it can match
the economic clout of the united states
so there you have it these are the big
myths about the chinese economy that are
repeated again and again in many media
outlets and in many passing
conversations so from now on keep an eye
on them but having come this far it's
now over to you do you think china will
recover from its most recent economic
problems have you ever considered
selling or investing in the asian giant
leave us your comments below and now if
you found this video interesting don't
forget to like it and subscribe to all
of us here at visualpolitik many thanks
also to our friends at value school for
their collaboration in making this video
all the best and i'll see you next time
[Music]